und während wir hier aufzeichnen findet
der große impfgipfel von bund und
ländern statt
im gegensatz zu ihnen liebe zuschauer
weiß ich also noch nicht was da
rausgekommen ist mein tipp mehrere
politiker haben mehr tempo beim impfen
gefordert sehr gute idee also völlig
neuer ansatz war sehr sehr gut und seit
heute gibt es ja auch wieder astrazeneca
ja jetzt wird games bis die spritze
gewalt also gute erst müssen neue
termine vergeben werden die alten haben
wir blöderweise gestrichen und die ärzte
müssen wieder zurückgeholt werden in die
impfzentren aber dann in sehr sehr sehr
seltenen fällen kann astrazeneca wohl zu
gehirn wenn thrombose führen
ja aber nicht impfen wäre die viel
größere tragödie klar die frage ist ob
die menschen nach dem ganzen hin und hat
noch vertrauen haben würden sie auch
astrazeneca nehmen fragen wir kurz
nachdem auch dieser impfstoff ganz
offiziell wieder als sicher eingestuft
worden ist
ich hatte den genommen denn neben
krediten durch den muslimen kleinen so
sieht das aus es wird geimpft was auf
den tisch kommt
astrazeneca ich würde es mir spritzen
lassen ehrlich ein anruf fünf minuten
später bin ich da ich sagte ein anruf
schade impfen impfen impfen
gerade jetzt wo die zahlen wieder
hochgehen hat auch mit mehr tests zu tun
klar trotzdem schlittern wir weiter
sehenden auges in die dritte welle vor
allem bei grundschule und kita kindern
ist die zahl der neuinfektionen
sprunghaft gestiegen
trotzdem musste nordrhein-westfalen
unbedingt zwei wochen vor den
osterferien die schulen aufmachen
einzelne kommunen wagen den aufstand
werden aber vom land zurück gepfiffen
duisburg hat eine inzidenz von 122 liegt
so ein sieben tagen über 100 und will
die schulen schließen
düren hat eine 7 tage incidence von
circa 240 und wollte nicht öffnen wegen
steigender infektionszahlen weil
dortmund alle schulen schließen bei chi
chi chi chi es nicht ja nicht sein dass
hier jeder bürgermeister oder
schulleiter selber nachdenkt wo kommen
wir da hin
was ist denn eigentlich mit der
notbremse die bremse sollte doch im
notfall
und wenn man schon mitten in der dritten
welle schulen öffnet muss man das
natürlich mit systematischem
flächendeckenden testen begleiten für
lehrer und schüler
sonst geht das nicht schule auf in
bergisch gladbach am anfang steht ein
corona selbst test die in spendierte die
feuerwehr weil die kulturbehörde in nrw
nicht zu schnell die von konnte
vielleicht sollte die feuerwehr das
kultusministerium übernehmen
und wenn dann der oberbürgermeister von
dortmund sagt ich kann das so nicht
verantworten schreibt ihm sein
landesvater folgendes ins poesiealbum
der hat einen incidents wert von 72 und
dem feld in dem moment nichts anderes
ein als die schulen zu schließen
ich finde nicht dass es gut ist wenn das
jeder so macht wie er gerade lust hat
und wie er selbst die prioritäten zu
lasten der kinder hier setzt doch eine
andere kinder
laschet in deinem bundesland müssen
schüler bei der feuerwehr test schorn
und du bestimmst den bürgermeister von
dortmund gibt es doch nicht und der
größte wahnsinn von allen meine damen
und herren ostern fliegt wohl ganz
deutschland nach mallorca
ja stand heute 0 quarantäne 0 test
pflicht bei rückkehr die groko
appelliert unnötige reisen zu
unterlassen kann aber nicht mal
verhindern dass vom staat gerettete
firmen wie tui und lufthansa hunderte
zusätzliche flüge nach malle anbieten
die man wirklich können jedem alles ganz
ehrlich aber wenn es am ende wieder
schulen und kitas aus baden andererseits
ich habe schlechtes gewissen sie nicht
zu hause bleiben mein leben ist passiert
das ist der schönste moment bis jetzt
seit der ganzen pandemie ich sitze hier
in meinem lieblingsort an rad mit meinem
russischen meine güte das wetter ein
trauma und ich brauch kein russisch und
in der sonne
ich kann genauso gut bei mir zu hause
auf dem balkon im nieselregen eierlikör
trinken deutschland wandert also
endgültig aus über ostern
was sagt denn das mallorquinische
fernsehen
mallorca jägern adresse logo massiver
proteste düsseldorf frankfurt hat das
kann dann lasse ich hier ist viel viel
liebe ins ist ein cellokonzert dem
australian die ganze bunte deportation
[Musik]
das ist hart mann oh mann
aber zurück zu astrazeneca da ist
kommunikativ wirklich alles schief
gelaufen alles verbockt worden was geht
überlegen sie mal erstmal gibt man das
zeug absurderweise nur für unter
65-jährige frau dann im stopp dann
wiederfreigabe die marke ist
angeschlagen noch schwerer zu vermarkten
sind aktuell wahrscheinlich nur sushi
aus fukushima surfbretter aus blei und
mobil ist aus fußnägel wenn wir nicht
aufpassen liegt das zeug irgendwann im
ein euro shop direkt neben den schalke
fan artikeln
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leichter last ich hab die schnauze
voll
loslassen abo da